[Music]
the design of this logo began in Seattle
in 1971 with three university friends
who really liked coffee they also really
liked the Herman Melville novel
moby-dick so much so they decided to
name their company after Captain Ahab's
ship but branding exact Terry heckler
decided Pequod coffee didn't sound quite
right so they went with the name of the
first mate
Starbuck heckler then child through
maritime books and found a 15th century
woodcut of a two-tailed siren instead of
luring sailors onto the rocks this
mythical mermaid would call people to
come and grab on the cup of coffee
initially her chest was bare but after
some complaints heckler redrew the
design with long hair that covered her
body the logo also went from brown to
green a symbol of freshness and growth
in 2011 the Starbuck siren was
redesigned with rounder details a longer
shadow was also introduced on the right
side of her nose a small element of
asymmetry which made her feel more human
she can be spotted in 76 countries and
markets helping Starbucks to reach a
brand value of more than eight point
seven billion dollars bold and alluring
this is the design that started with a
myth and became a coffee legend
[Music]
you